all right let's return now uh to the
race to become the next leader of the
conservative party and of course our
next prime minister i'm very pleased to
say that joining me now is the
conservative mp sir ian duncan smith and
former leader of course of the
conservation industry who is backing us
are you the campaign manager well i'm
helping overall oversee the campaign but
uh well essentially there are plenty of
other people doing stuff absolutely
right so look um let's start with the
cost of living crisis yes it's the guys
are not going to get together let's
trust them which you know are not going
to get together at all why is that and
shouldn't they
no i don't think so this is a contest to
be the leader of the conservative party
and then obviously the prime minister
uh one of those people is not in cabinet
the other one is it would be quite wrong
for example of liz because of the
campaign to try and direct what the
government is doing at the moment to
suit herself i don't know what they
would achieve together by agreeing what
i don't reassure people who are really
anxious about their bills going on i
think the government can reassure people
that they're looking at it right now the
government is actually going through
what the options are where the problems
exist and we need to understand that so
there's a plan in place when we get to
the point where we have a prime minister
with options should that need a rise and
that's exactly where we are and i think
that's the important bit the government
has all the mechanisms it has all the
enormous power of government to be able
to look at this to get the facts right
the figures right
and to look at the way they do it i mean
i was critical of the 50 we just had a
15 billion pound payout which is gone
and we're still waiting for half of that
to get through to people you know and
it's still not enough as well well we
say it's not enough but that's because
things are shifting so what we're saying
is this money is already going out at
the moment much has not landed in
people's pockets uh and i'm critical in
the sense that i don't believe that we
should have handed out money across the
board to lots of people like you and me
where we're not in the same predicament
as people on low income so i would like
to see if we have to do this much more
targeted on people on low income
targeted support work as necessary and
that can be done by the government prior
the leadership election being completed
through something like universal credit
which you of course designed yeah i
would like to see you know it's a
personal view i'd like to see universal
credit use more because it's the only
system we have which targets whole
households it knows what the household
income is it knows therefore who really
needs the money so instead of spreading
the money all the way up the chain
to 400 pounds to you and me i think the
reality is that this is what liz trust
has been talking about we want targeted
support if we have to do this we have to
look at the events of what's going on
and see what the forecasts are and then
make that decision and one of the
criticisms and one of the reasons why
people should get around the table now
is that to get those uh increases in
universal credit or whatever change
we're gonna make whether it's a taper
rate or an or an uplift you need to
start that process now and if you don't
start it now you're not gonna make it
for october the first well the key thing
is you have to get this right you have
to get it focused if you try and rush
this process and i've been in government
long enough to know when things happen
and people go bang we're going to have
to sort this out what happens is you
waste a lot of money and you miss the
targets you need to get to that's why
it's really important for government
right now to do it liz trust has been
crystal clear from the beginning that
should the need arise she will do
whatever is necessary but right now on a
campaign is not feasible for two
candidates to literally make up uh
amounts of money on the back of an
envelope what she wants to do on day one
to start with is to make sure that we
reduce the burden of taxation because
why
right now we face the potential of a
recession if you have a recession on top
of this cost of living crisis it will be
an utter human disaster we need to avoid
recession
at all costs in the course of this
winter we need to do something about
that that's where lower tax is important
but getting targeted help to people she
said she's certainly prepared to do and
look at as and when the government and
of course you'll know that there is a
debate where the cutting taxes will
stave off the recession which the bank
of england says is coming but let's
stick with universal of course it will
because let me just what can i just
explain something to you quickly the
bank of england's forecasts now for
recession are based on the highest level
of tax that we've had in a generation if
we start to bring that down yep their
forecasts shift all the independent
economists
show that the best way to stay stable is
to be out of that recession forecast if
inflation increases as well caused by
those taxes they're bringing interest
rates in to get inflation down by all
means do that but don't kill people's
eco economics off and put them on on the
serene you know that there are
economists who can agree on the other
side who will say that well cutting
taxes not many independent economists
disagree with most of them i mean some
of them some of them do but let's stick
with universal credit how long would it
take for that money to go through to
people well that's the key question uh
and that's why the government needs to
look at that right now and the key i
mean immediately because by october the
first year bills are going to go up so
will it be there by then yeah but the
key things with benefit systems is you
have to change things through
legislation quickly the question is how
quickly can you do that to make changes
to this process and those are the key
elements that have got to be looked at
now by the government which is why the
government is right to be looking at it
now in preparation for somebody that
takes over so they have instantaneous
possibilities there that they can pull
the levers and get them you can't
guarantee that the extra money will be
there by the first of october well it
depends what you're actually asking them
to do that's what the government's got
to look at all i'm saying to you is
in in line with the urgency of the
requirement and people's incomes and
those who most need it that's the
important point the reality is the
government has to find ways to make sure
that that money gets to those targeted
individuals that's what the government
needs to look at now which is why as i
said earlier on there's no point in two
candidates meeting together to try and
figure out what they would do they're
not in command of the details the
government is here to do that with the
government so the government will do
anything because the government said
they have to wait until the candidates
no no no the government has been working
on this for weeks by the way i know
because i talk to government ministers
who have been working with their
departments to do it so they've been
working for some time what they're doing
now is getting ready to make sure those
decisions are able to be made should
they need to be made they will make
those decisions on the basis of solid
advice argument well maybe i'll put it
to you that the assurance is not getting
there for people but i do want to move
on well because you know at the end of
it all they're worried and we have to
make sure that they know that the
government will step in where necessary
i want to
bring something to your attention this
idea of conversion therapy is a policy
that was put in place uh put pushed
through by liz trust when she was a
qualities minister yep this is what you
had to say about conversion therapy just
recently uh this is liz truster's uh
commitment to it yes i agree with that
by the way you you do because you said
you said recently that no i stopped
banning things
you're looking to report on something i
said i said my personal opinion is that
the bill itself
to deliver that isn't in the right shape
to deliver it we have to get the balance
right between what you do to try and
sort people quite rightly to protect
people who make decisions but at the
same time to make sure that you don't
collide with the rights that people have
to freedom of speech and things and
we've got to work that out so this bill
needs to be reworked looked at again
that's my personal view i agree with her
that the point of what we're trying to
do is to get to a point where you can
protect those who need that protection
that's important so this trust will
carry on with the bill to ban gateway
right now it's suspended and we need to
look at that bill as to how we get that
done the key thing that she will carry
on with i mean well liz trust has made
it very clear in that she's in favor of
it quite rightly but my point is as i
was saying the bill itself we need to
make sure delivers what we're after
without the unintended consequences and
knock-ons that go on and that's
important with legislation you can't
rush it of course make sure it's done so
the objective
i completely agree with okay let me talk
to you quickly about uh the climate
crisis you'll know that many
conservative supporters want us to
change our climate targets for 2050. do
you think that because of the situation
right now we should push those targets
back
well i think what we've committed to is
reaching those targets of 2050 they're
very advanced there's a lot that needs
to be done clearly but the key point is
we have to do it in a way that doesn't
damage lives at the same time so this is
why liz trust has made it very clear
that what she'll do is suspend that levy
that green levy on individuals
costs about 153 pounds for people to do
that at a time when they are really
short of money and they need help that's
one thing that you and fragan have to
deal with and we suspend that for the
moment whilst we make sure we tackle the
cost of living crisis we will return
back to the process of making sure we
achieve that 2050 target that's what she
is committed to and that's what she
wants to do but what she wants to make
sure is you don't do it on the backs of
people who can't afford what you're
actually making them pay and that means
their lives will change syrian duncan
smith formerly the conservative back of
this trust appreciate your time this
morning sir